we got this from forbes
new york's largest health care provider
fires 1 400 employees who refuse to get
vaccinated can i just say that um firing
health care uh employees during a
pandemic sounds like not a good idea
it's like a bad idea maybe yep that was
the first that was the first thought
that that crossed my mind and my and my
cousin's a nurse and she worked with
covet patients and she said the same
thing she said this is this is
disgusting to do to these people they
were called our heroes we were literally
uh
hitting pots and pans outside supporting
them and now they're literally being
kicked to the streets with a caveat
because a lot of the people who are
being fired are being denied
unemployment benefits as another
draconian step by the new york state
that is going out of their way to make
sure that people can't have enough money
to feed their families to feed their
loved ones and and this healthcare
provider it was the northwell health
company thousand four hundred people
will go
with with with a situation where they
can't pay the bills
i got a friend
very very you know pro joe biden
anti-trump the whole time screaming
ignoring the riots your typical
establishment liberal type just pro
corporate chill and boy was it funny
when they started posting on facebook
how they're terrified the vaccine
mandates are here i'm going to lose my
job i can't believe this is wrong why
are they doing this and i'm like bro you
voted for it yeah you voted for it for
this yeah like
you got i got to say i feel bad
and i also want to laugh at the same
time i'm like to see the cathartic it's
the cathartic release of like everything
you were saying was a lie i told you it
was a lie now here you are frantic
but i feel bad because the whole point
of me opposing this stuff was so that my
friends wouldn't be dealing with this
but boy you know i'm sure everybody
knows some of these people that just
won't listen you know why because the
demoralization is complete as yuri
besmanov said you can show them the true
and correct authentic authentic
information and they will not accept it
another thing to really consider here is
that these are medical professionals on
the front lines these are the people
that helped cure people with covet these
are the people administering the vaccine
these are the people that were literally
on the front lines if there's any
experience that these people have if
there's any thoughts that these people
have we should be listening to them we
should have a conversation with them we
should not throw them to the streets and
that's exactly what new york state is
doing in a two-tier society that is now
here and it's disgusting to see our
you know heroes medical workers that are
volunteering
many times working overtime helping
people in their worst states now being
thrown to the streets well that being
said i wonder how many of these people
got fired were dancing in the hallways
and you know that kind of stuff probably
not these people in particular but uh at
the same time look there's a lot of
criticism to go around for a lot of
these people too who went out from their
new york health you know care facilities
went out in the street clapping and
cheering for black lives matter and like
who were openly defying coveted lockdown
measures so
and we're saying that black lives matter
protests were actually good for covid
and stopping the spread and counter
protests were not i want to i want to
ask you luke because uh last week when
we had shane cashman on the show he said
something really interesting to me
and i'm curious what your thoughts on
this too he said new york has already
seceded
they've already you need a passport to
go there right if you don't have the
required you need a physical card proof
to actually use the services of new york
as if it were a different country and if
you don't have what's required on the
card which is not just your veterans
your identification as well you it used
to be in new york you could walk into
any place and buy whatever you wanted
now you need an id
and your your your vaccine passport so
he was like
they've implemented rules already that
have basically excised half the
population from being able to go there
that's like soft seating as it is
exactly it's it's a different society
that plays by different rules compare
new york to florida new york then uh i
mean florida that the case numbers
dropped according to some estimates even
95 percent uh and when you go to florida
the restaurants are open stadiums are
open schools are opens there's no
restrictions there's no lockdowns
there's no two-tier society there's no
papers please everywhere you go so so
we're seeing something that is slowly
spreading west virginia is the same give
us some credit well it depends also
where you go there's liberal cities uh
everywhere even in florida like in tampa
they're trying to implement uh vax
passports as well that needs to be
called out and uh and they're fighting
with the state so so there's there's
different people pushing different
things but if you remember one of the
first things that i brought up last year
the first time i went on this show was
the need for a peaceful divorce
a divorce between the statists and the
people who actually believe in personal
freedom and personal liberty now we talk
about it almost every single day well so
so but let's you you were saying that
new york you're not even noticing any of
these things no no but i agree with what
you say and i i want to comment on that
because i was with my friend
my friend sarah who
uh served in the army for five years and
then came out as transgender and now
she's living her best life as a woman um
she said it the best we were we were
traveling from nashville which was super
liberal to north carolina which was more
conservative we saw the differences just
from driving from state to state and the
way she explained it was was really well
put she's like you know what at this
point i don't care about california
anymore if they want socialism let them
have it because i don't live there
that's the way she put it i mean she
they voted for that i don't live there i
i she's like we tried we tried to
explain to them that this isn't gonna
work it's never worked and she's like
it's the united states is in a very
interesting situation because we have 50
different states for that reason because
each of those states needs has different
needs
and has different laws because that's
the way we were designed yeah um and
it's interesting it will be interesting
to see what
flourishes and what fails and i think
right now
from the for the most part i think
california and new york city are are
failing
52 percent of biden of trump support
trump voters want peaceful divorce 41 of
biden voters we're getting close yeah
but the biden administration is bailing
out new york and california giving them
everyone's tax dollars financing a lot
of their sanctuary cities financing a
lot of their insane policies financing
just the the the total marxist and again
if marxists want to live in in communism
i don't want to stop you from doing that
but stop forcing other people to do it
as well i lived in new york city we
actually
lived very close to each other we didn't
know each other like this is the first
time they were schoolmates yeah we were
actually schoolmates which was pretty
interesting uh but but i left i said i'm
done i'm done incentivizing my taxes i
don't want them going here it's
unethical it's immoral for my taxes to
be going here my energy my time my
social circle it was hard to end all
that i literally went up to new
hampshire no plan and i became a part of
the free state project and i love it
there and i love coming down here i love
being in florida and i love
incentivizing and voting with my actions
what i personally like and i think if we
need to
do anything it's to be aware of the
small decisions that we make every day
in our existence because those decisions
matter the most and they mean the most
as far as impact because again they
could only get away with this if we
allow it to get away with it you can't
comply your way out of tyranny it's not
going to happen uh and what's happening
in new york california is absolutely
tyrannical you want to live under it you
love it stay there i would love this to
instead of referring to these cities as
liberal just start referring to them as
authoritarian because i'm a liberal i'm
very liberal in my behavior i'm not a
liberal i'm just super liberal i like
liberal with sexuality liberal with what
you do with your life you know
libertarian is liberal i mean that's the
same freaking root
and yeah i hate that they took that word
from us i really do because we are we
are so we call it classic liberal
classical liberals are like
classical liberalism is a center-right
position that means towards no no it's
always been oh yeah that leans towards
libertarianism and then
what we refer to as traditional liberals
is actually social liberal
so like i've actually read you know a
little bit in different writers about
social liberalism versus classical
liberalism they're very much the same
and that's that's how it used to be it
used to be classical liberalism versus
uh social liberalism where you have
social liberals saying this was like the
civil rights movement hey the state
needs to stop this and the classical
liberals were like private businesses
can do what they want live and let live
yeah now it's the
democrats that are actually the ones
saying private corporations could do
what they want but the problem is these
are massive multinational billion dollar
unaccountable corporations so they're
basically fascists yeah when social
liberalism goes too far you get
authoritarianism when you have the state
trying to enforce civil rights that's a
form of authoritarianism very small
amount to do some good but if it goes
too far and then you start to force
people to take medicine and force people
to stand this way and say this thing
that's madly authoritarian and very
dangerous you know i'd say it was a
slippery slope but i think it's a sheer
cliff right what what we're on you know
luke was saying like we're on the
precipice and i'm kind of like uh we
went off it we went off the press you
know i wound up like we're just falling
now i wanted to mention the you you
mentioned the 50 was the 52 percent of
trump voters wanted to secede in 41 but
that actually comes from a poll the
daily mail posted it where they've only
pulled two thousand and twelve people
and then they extrapolated two thousand
and twelve people to the entire united
states and the the the name the headline
is america thinks the unthinkable more
than half of trump voters want red and
blue states to succeed they only pulled
two thousand people slow down for a
thousand trump voters let's let's slow
down for a second that's actually a
pretty large sample size 2012 people out
of 350 million yes that's not large that
it is it's a large sample size for a
poll maybe yes but it's a terrible way
to frame just because it's a two
thousand person polls that more than
half of the trump voters want right i'm
so i'm explaining to you as much as i'm
not a fan of a lot of these polls and
don't trust them
standards for polling that's actually
crap standards and we got to talk about
now you can have a poll that's
disingenuous and you can have a poll
that's misframed and this has been
misframed well i don't think it's
miserable it says that more than half of
the trump voters want it and they only
pulled a thousand of them
that's that's that's how they they made
a claim about 80 million people based
off of a poll of a thousand people i i
understand your argument but there's no
point in continuing if you don't know
how the polls well i'm saying that it's
a dangerous precedent to allow people to
frame polls like this the problem with
polling is that they'll say something
like this like let me ask you a question
ariel do you think that we should use
some of our tax dollars towards green
energy so that we can you know make the
air cleaner and and our and our you know
our water cleaner sure okay let me ask
another question do you think that we
should have a massive government
overhaul an increase in taxes
restricting what private businesses can
do
no okay you're for and against the green
lady right yeah exactly it's the way you
frame it yeah so the question you asked
we'll get someone so we'll say like we
asked you know now
polls typically release their
questionnaire so they don't do that as
overtly the problem with political
polling is that they'll always interview
more democrats the problem isn't the
sample size there's a 500 is a bad
sample size but what they do is they
target regions
they'll go into certain areas with
certain voting demographics and they'll
look at the age the breakdown and then
they'll take a sample of those people
and use them as a representative sample
it's not just two thousand random people
it is it is it and you can look at the
the the um
i forgot i'm forgetting the word you can
look at actually how they calculated
this they'll show you all the math
they'll show you all the questions
that's actually not bad 2000. now you
need to check the question they asked
but it seems like that actually tracks
with other data we've seen where 37.2
percent of voters in general from
independents not just uh republicans and
democrats
37.2 want their region to break off and
form its own country
okay but this is like if you asked the
four of us in the room a question no it
isn't it is but okay a thousand let's
say you grabbed two thousand people too
we can't just keep listen to me you
bring the two thousand people into a
room and you ask them to a poll and then
you say half of all people think that
it's not that's not what you did you
pulled two thousand people ian you need
to stop okay we're gonna move on i
definitely want to move on because you i
you you need to read how polls work i
know how polls work they pulled 2012
people and then said that it was half of
the people okay and talk about something
else read about polls we'll come back to
this
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you